I was born into war right into it people
think they understand pain but they have
no concept of it what's the most pain
you've ever felt maybe the kind that
leaves you more mushy and then wait no
stop what in the actual ass bail what
why why are the visual effects not done
it's a metal arm it's not like we're
trying to remove a mustache oh [ __ ] it
I'll do it myself
I'm cable and I'm from the future and I
like blowing [ __ ] up
oh no sheriff Deadpool you know you're a
lot taller in the shut up you little
[ __ ] take this regeneration powers
activate that's not something cable I
got the stones to help you no biting
they're done already oh wow that was
unrealistically fast okay innit
your time's up you dumb [ __ ] well that's
just lazy writing
[Music]
hey everybody we finally got our first
look at cable let's break this down
that's just I'm a lazy riding if you
couldn't tell if they were making fun of
the entire movie not just the trailer
but obviously the you know they were
also poking fun at the fact that they
weren't quite finished with it like oh
come on we can't finish a freakin metal
arm never mind I'll do it myself
somewhere in the world Henry cabals
mustache is twitching in anger too it's
not like we're trying to remove a
freaking mustache you didn't think that
they're gonna market this Deadpool movie
without taking some shots at Justice
League remember when Batman V Superman
came out and there was all those viral
promos those were an official movie
promos this is something that a fan did
but I think they're just picking up on
that idea but justice league is kind of
an easy target if you're freaking out
about this you have no idea we found out
when they're dropping the venom movie
trailer so I'll talk about that at the
end of the video too
if you guys didn't know this is only the
beginning - there's gonna be a Deadpool
TV series that's gonna premiere after
the movie comes out sometime we don't
have a firm premiere date for that yet
but obviously the movie got bumped up
because of all the shuffling the Fox did
with their movies so we get Deadpool two
weeks earlier than we were originally
going to get it it would be crazy if
they drop their TV series during the
summer right after this but I have a
feeling that they're trying to piggyback
on some of this good PR there'll be more
updates about that soon don't worry it's
all about the movie right now I think we
almost see a proto version of x-force
too when they're on the back of the
chopper here but these don't look like
the people that are going to be part of
x-force there's a lot of genuine x-men
characters that'll join the team but I
think for the most part all the scenes
that cable is in during the trailer is
stuff from present-day like even though
it looks like it could be from some
crazy sci-fi world when he's in this
apartment that looks like it's been
blown to hell but the key to placing him
in the timeline is when he's walking
past these two people and it looks like
one of them is wearing a bargain bin
t-shirt from Target like seriously this
does not look like something from the
future so when he opens his eye here and
looks like he's waking up in the past
after having time-traveled and then goes
on his mission but I do love the wit
like he goes to this big long diatribe
but you don't know what pain is imagine
the most painful thing that's ever
happened to you and by the end of the
trailer Deadpool is just like that just
this is lazy riding so one they're
making fun of sequels
two they're making fun of them
selves just in general because depo
always makes fun of himself but there's
also the dolls that he plays with to
tell you what the story of the movie is
so like usually Deadpool and him
fighting in the middle of the street
that's actually stuff that happens
during the movie they don't officially
canonized this character is butterball
we get another shot of Domino in that
building that he was burning down with
the humanity sticker Biden so it looks
like it's confirmed humanity now but it
also might be the purifiers like we
talked about that during the last
trailer just because of some of these
banners I am really curious to see who
Terry Crews winds up playing but I do
love this action scene here like it does
look they mostly finished it you see
cable running and jumping on top of this
that's how powerful he is now his powers
are mostly telepathy and telekinesis but
the techno-organic virus that he's
infected with usually holds that in
check a little bit so he actually can
become much more powerful I don't know
how they're gonna explain the virus
during the movie or if they're not gonna
include it at all but that's part of the
reason why he looks the way he does the
other part is because he really does
come from that post-apocalyptic future
timeline but it's all Age of Apocalypse
stuff we don't know what's gonna happen
with strife if they're gonna include him
in the movie I have a feeling they're
gonna focus mostly just on introducing
cable and then maybe they'll get into
more of his deep mythology during the
x-force movies because they signed Josh
Brolin for five movies when he signed
the contract for cable so I don't think
that anything is gonna change with
whatever five Deadpool Universe movies
they're planning on making because
that's Deadpool three x-force maybe an
x-force sequel who knows what's gonna
happen after Deadpool three I'm sure
they will continue making Deadpool but I
think they're just planning for a
trilogy of x-force films and a trilogy
of Deadpool films but the rest of this
is them just assaulting that DMC base it
looks like Deadpool actually gets bagged
in tags maybe he does that so that he
can get into the facility and then they
come and take it down but if you look in
the background of the scene where he's
playing with a doll so you can actually
see a bunch of stuff from the earlier
trailers in the background like this is
the painting from the Bob Rost trailer
this is a bunch of objects that he's
used to kill people it looks like
there's a tip jar sitting on this table
here and then I think for the most part
the story they're trying to convey the
reason why cable came back is because he
needs to save one of these people here
but I don't think that the teddy bear
belongs to that person I think the teddy
bear belongs to
him and he just kept it within this
whole time but there's just a wink to
his comic book origin I'll be interested
to see because by this time negasonic is
a full-blown x-men her powers look like
they've gotten that much more powerful
I'll be interested to see how much
specific x-men main movie stuff that
they referenced because they took all
kinds of shots at him in the last
Deadpool movie
now that you have Cyclops and Madeline
priors child I'll just be interested to
see what kind of shots they take at that
so obviously the plot of the movie and
the way that the first-step whole movie
changes the comics a little bit this
will change cables back story in the
comics just a little bit but there'll be
all kinds of Easter eggs for everything
that happened so if you're a big cable
fan your big x-force fan they'll have
all that stuff in here but let me know
what you guys think of this and what do
you think of him live tweeting the
Superbowl like that was actually just a
big joke about how Fox didn't want to
spend the extra
tens of millions of dollars that it
would cost for that 30-second ad because
they knew they were gonna be dropping
this a couple days later but I know
everybody's still fascinated by the idea
of that Deadpool TV series who's gonna
do the voice of the character is gonna
be Ryan Reynolds is gonna be Nolan North
is it gonna be somebody else because it
takes a long time to animate episodes I
don't think we're gonna see footage of
that or any teasers until we get closer
to the actual Deadpool movie coming out
like they'll just piggyback on the
marketing for the movie like oh you just
saw a Deadpool movie guess what we have
a Deadpool TV series that's gonna be
coming of course when that comes I will
totally do videos for it so be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'm doing a
Marvel giveaway too I'll announce a
winner the next time I post an Avengers
video that should be tomorrow there's a
new flash trailer I'm working on later
today the other big news is is that
they're dropping the trailer for the
venom movie tomorrow so of course I'll
do a video for that but as long as you
click that Bell and turn on
notifications you should be fine but
click here to rewatch the Avengers
trailer and click here to watch the
other Deadpool trailers thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]